[Applaus]
yes
so soll das nicht sein sind beide haben
sich nicht getrennt und drehen sich
gerade unkontrolliert
ja da ist es da ist es passiert
großes Boom
das ist kein hey ja das war gerade total
okay das Pad ist nicht zerstört worden
wir haben maxq überlebt separation hat
nicht funktioniert okay aber Leute
Starship funktioniert das was ich
Ingenieure da gedacht haben funktioniert
und das ist super super
der erste Orbital Flug der größten und
stärksten Rakete der Welt hat leider
nicht geklappt aber auch wenn es gerade
ein Fehlversuch gegeben hat SpaceX hat
uns über die letzten Jahre positiv
überrascht deshalb erfahrt ihr heute
alles was es Spannendes über das
Starship und seine Entwicklung zu
erzählen gibt seit unserem letzten Video
gab es nämlich einige tolle Neuerungen
und wir sind optimistisch dass das
wichtigste Projekt von SpaceX schon sehr
bald erfolgreich sein wird und ihr denkt
nach diesem Video bestimmt genau so
[Musik]
SpaceX hat sein Versprechen gehalten
schnell und viel zu scheitern wir haben
über 20 Prototypen gezählt die seit
Beginn des starship-programms geplant
wurden einige wurden nicht einmal gebaut
manche wurden gebaut und dann einfach
wieder demontiert aber einige wurden
getestet
und man hat viel daraus gelernt zunächst
einmal wurde das Raptor Triebwerk
weiterentwickelt die ganz neue Raptor 2
Version hat ein vereinfachtes Design ist
leichter und hat mehr Schubkraft als
seine Vorgänger trotzdem benötigt die
boosterstufe des starships 33 dieser
Triebwerke ein einzelnes Rap da zwei
Triebwerk hat eine Schubleistung von 230
Tonnen die 33 Triebwerk zusammen haben
also eine Gesamtschule Leistung von
7.590 Tonnen das ist so viel wie der
Eiffelturm + 48 afrikanische Elefanten
Bullen rund 50 sehr große Blauwale oder
etwa 4000 Tesla Model 3 stattdessen
schiebt die boosterstufe nur das
eigentliche Starship an das ist Starship
selber wiederum braucht nur sechs Raptor
2 Triebwerke drei sind für die
Verwendung in der Atmosphäre optimiert 3
für den Weltraum z.B um nach der
Trennung von Booster einen Orbit um die
Erde zu erreichen
ein riesiger Meilenstein war dass
Starship wieder zu landen
wiederverwendbare Raketen sind ja der
Unique Selling Point von SpaceX und für
den Langzeiterfolg des starships
unumgänglich und sie haben es geschafft
im Mai 2021 flog ein Prototyp bis zu
einer Höhe von etwa 10 km dort schwebte
das Starship ein wenig und führte dann
den Berlin Flop durch in der
horizontalen Position konnte es den
Sinkflug wie ein Skydiver machen kurz
vor dem Touchdown richtete sich das
Starship wieder auf landete erfolgreich
und diesmal explodierte auch danach
nichts mehr auch bei der Rückkehr aus
dem All soll's Starship mit der
Bauchseite zuerst in die Atmosphäre
eindringen deshalb hat es dort einen
Hitzeschild die Entwicklung des Starship
schreitet also voran aber was genau soll
das Starship Programm überhaupt leisten
eines Tages soll es Starship auf dem
Mars landen und dann wieder auf die Erde
zurückkehren die Vision ist mit 1000
starships eine Millionen Tonnen an Crew
und Ressourcen auf den Mars zu bringen
um dort eine permanente Kolonie
aufzubauen in der Kolonie soll auch
Methan als Treibstoff für den Rückflug
produziert werden diese Pläne scheinen
sich nicht geändert zu haben aber ob es
überhaupt passiert muss die Zukunft
zeigen zu Philosophie der Firma gehört
ja auch Pläne der Realität anzupassen
sogar Elon Musk verschiebt das Datum für
den ersten Marsflug immer weiter nach
hinten aktuell sagt er es seit 2029
soweit unsere gewagte Voraussage das
wird wahrscheinlich auch noch mal
verschoben auf mittlere Sicht will
SpaceX mit dem Starship eine neue
Infrastruktur schaffen mit über 1000
Starts im Jahr mit wiederverwendbaren
Raketen sollen die Kosten pro Start auf
ein Tausendstel dessen gedrückt werden
was ein starkes SLS kostet mit dem SMS
ist die NASA ja vor kurzem zum Mond
geflogen und das war super teuer
man kann aber auch hier nicht sagen ob
space x das schafft denn ob sich das
System entsprechend skalieren lässt und
sich dann auch genug Kunden finden kann
man jetzt einfach noch nicht wissen Elon
musks wiederholte Aussage der Start des
starships würde nur 10 Millionen
US-Dollar kosten ist schon deshalb rein
theoretisch weil es Starship noch gar
nicht kommerziell fliegt ein Staat der
viel kleineren Felge nein von SpaceX
kostet jedenfalls fast 70 Millionen
Dollar anstatt der fällt in heavy die
bisher größte Rakete von SpaceX kostet
rund 100 Millionen es wurde früher auch
öfter behauptet dass man mit Starship
irgendwann Langstreckenflüge machen
könnte also von Berlin durch den Orbit
nach New York in einer halben Stunde und
so aber dazu haben wir nur veraltete
Informationen gefunden die einzige
Quelle auf der Space x Webseite die wir
gefunden haben ist über die normale
Navigation auf der Seite gar nicht mehr
zu finden aber Suchmaschinen finden Sie
noch und das Projekt ist nicht ganz vom
Tisch Ende 2020 hat das US Militär
angekündigt mit Space x den Transport
von Truppen und Equipment zu testen
konzentriert sich stattdessen auf die
realistischeren und vor allem auch
aktuelleren mittelfristigen Ziele für
die bereits geplanten Missionen und
Anwendungen braucht SpaceX nämlich das
Starship in verschiedenen Varianten eine
Variante wird Satelliten für das
staling-netzwerk in den Orbit bringen
bei einer Nutzlast von 100 Tonnen könnte
das Starship rund 380 der alten Starling
Satelliten auf einmal transportieren die
sollen einer nach dem anderen um Orbit
positioniert werden können auch für die
Forschung ist das Starship interessant
eine Wissenschaftlerin der NASA hat in
einem Interview gesagt dass sie mit dem
Starship gerne Roboter zum Mond schicken
würde die könnten dort
bohrungenunternehmen und das Starship
würde dann mit vielen Tonnen an
mondproben zurückkehren richtig konkret
wird es für das Starship human landing
System HLS ich gebe zu in unserem
letzten Video zum Starship klang so als
wäre schon klar gewesen dass NASA und
SpaceX zusammen zu Mond fliegen würden
tatsache ist dass zu der Zeit erstmal
nur ein technisches Design als Vorschlag
für die Nase angefertigt wurde
SpaceX stand da aber noch in Konkurrenz
mit Blue Origin und deinetics erst im
April 2021 hat das starschiff von SpaceX
den festen Zuschlag von der NASA
erhalten wir konnten also so ein
bisschen in die Zukunft gucken dagegen
hat vor allem blue Origin wiederholt
offiziell protestiert aber ihre Einwände
wurden alle abgeschmettert es wird also
ein SpaceX Starship sein dass laut
Zeitplan 2025 bei der Artemis 3 Mission
eine Astronautin und einen Astronauten
zum Mond bringt dafür braucht Starship
natürlich eine Kabine mit
Lebenserhaltung für die besonderen
Verhältnisse auf dem mondplan SpaceX
spezielle landestelzen zusätzliche
Solarpanels und weitere steuertriebwerke
für das Tasche außerdem braucht es
natürlich Luftschleusen und einen
Fahrstuhl über den die Crew auf die
Oberfläche gelangt im November 2022 hat
sich SpaceX noch einmal gegen die
Konkurrenz durchgesetzt nun sollen sie
auch für Artemis 4 ein Starship HLS
bereitstellen dazu muss es insgesamt
vier astronautinnen und Astronauten
beherbergen und mehr Ausrüstung zum Mond
transportieren können außerdem soll es
am Luna Gateway andocken können das ist
eine Station die die artemismissionen
vom Orbit um den Mond aus unterstützen
soll alles über die artemismissionen
erfahrt übrigens in dieser Playlist hier
SpaceX führt übrigens auch jetzt schon
bemannte Missionen aus allerdings nicht
mit dem Starship sondern der Dragon
Kapsel die mit der Fake in ein Rakete in
den Orbit gebracht wird apropos erinnert
ihr euch wie SpaceX einen Tesla in den
Weltraum geschickt hat das war bei der
Demonstration der faking heavy Rakete
als wir das erste Mal über Starship
berichtet haben saß und so aus als wäre
fällt in heavy sehr schnell überflüssig
gemacht worden und das hat sich wohl
geändert die fällt in heavy ist zwar
bisher nur vier Mal gestartet aber es
sind noch 12 weitere Starts bis
einschließlich 2026 geplant damit werden
die Entwicklungskosten vermutlich doch
noch gedeckt werden auch wenn vor allem
die späteren Flüge dann vielleicht doch
vom Starship übernommen werden sollten
aber das nächste was klappen muss ist
der orbitalflug auch wenn der erste
Versuch jetzt missglückt ist
schnell und viel zu scheitern gehört ja
eigentlich zu Philosophie von SpaceX
SpaceX hat seine ursprünglich geplante
Timeline nicht eingehalten zum Mars wird
es vermutlich nicht so bald gehen und
auch der erste orbitalflug wurde erst
seit 2020 immer wieder verschoben und
geglückt ist er ja jetzt auch noch nicht
wer sich im Forschung und Entwicklung
auskennt weiß aber irgendetwas
Unvorhergesehenes kommt immer dazwischen
und drei bis vier Jahre Verspätung sind
bei so einem mega ambitionierten Projekt
eigentlich wirklich vertretbar ich
drücke den Space extrem deswegen ganz
fest die Daumen für den nächsten Versuch
Starship in den Orbit zu bekommen
irgendwann wird es klappen und dann
können wir alle super gespannt darauf
sein wie die Atem des Mondmissionen
gelingen wir halten euch auf jeden Fall
auf dem laufenden danke fürs zuschauen
und bleibt neugierig euer Cedric